you can't hide from your problems
forever eventually they're going to
catch up with you like when I tell my
twins to clean up their room and they
just shove everything in the closet it
doesn't work once you open that door
it's all going to come crashing down the
longer you leave it the worse it gets
Ronald Reagan knew that better than
anybody in the 70s and 80s parts of New
York looked like a third world country
bombed out version of what we know today
when Reagan was running for president he
went straight into the worst part of
town and talked to the people who lived
there
to demonstrate his concern the
Republican nominee traveled to the South
Bronx where rampant Urban blight has
left dozens of city blocks of virtual
Wasteland in a shouting match with
residents many of whom demanded jobs
Reagan replied I can't do a damn thing
for you if I don't get elected
bring that about and not with a kind of
a promise that Carter made they weren't
happy to see Reagan and most of them
probably didn't vote for him but it was
important for Reagan to see what they
were going through and there's a reason
the Bronx doesn't look like that anymore
because powerful people saw the problem
and they knew how to fix it Biden went
to our Southern border this week but he
didn't really see what we've been
showing you for the last two years
before Air Force One touched down they
cleaned it all up through the tents in
the garbage took the families off the
cold streets and just plugged the holes
in the wall
all of a sudden the migrants were gone
for the first time in years it was quiet
in El Paso someone wanted to get rid of
him before the president and all the
national press came to town
border patrol and local cops started
locking up migrants in the middle of the
night
Texans know this is a total con job
listen to what ranchers had to say about
the polished El Paso Biden visited
it's a mess
he went to El Paso everything's picked
up everything's clean everybody's kind
of like on their best behavior I would
think that's what he's seeing so he
doesn't really see what's happening on a
daily basis I think it's absurd honestly
I I think that there's hundreds of miles
of border that is being inundated our
border patrol are being overworked our
law enforcement are being tasked beyond
measure and he chooses to go to El Paso
that by the way has been cleaned up
before he got there I'm not saying he
needs to dive into the Rio Grande or you
know wrestle a coyote but the least he
could do is meet with a migrant even CNN
agrees
that's why the president is being
criticized by both sides because of what
he didn't see so let me show you because
this is one of the migrant camps that's
here in downtown El Paso and you know
the immigration Advocates here in El
Paso and Governor Greg Abbott usually
don't agree on much but they do raise
the same question if President Biden
came here to El Paso to see the reality
on the ground about the border and he
didn't come here what's considered the
epicenter of this crisis did he leave
with a clear understanding Biden was too
busy touring a parking lot of a
government building
he didn't want to really see what was
happening and he didn't meet with any of
the migrants or as his wife calls him
tacos Joe knew if he met a migrant in
front of a camera they'd probably give
him a big hug and say gracias they love
Joe I mean he opened the country to him
when his motorcade blew past a group of
migrants lined up at the border
they cheered
unlike Joe Prime Time talks to migrants
when a bus came to New York we asked
them what they wanted to say to Joe
what is your message to Joe Biden we are
completely grateful for the opportunity
that he has given us thanks for the
support to all the Venezuelans coming
here we were happily welcome thanks to
Biden the president this is just a photo
op for the President White House sources
says pivoting to the Center for 2024.
remember the last time Joe pivoted he
broke his foot chasing his dog
this time looks even worse Biden's doing
a photo up next to the wall he defunded
and said doesn't work
there's not a single thing that building
a wall or imposing it I'm posing another
tariff can address on any of these
issues there will not be another foot of
Wall constructed on my Administration
and there he is right there walking next
to the Border agents whose colleagues he
called racist and spread a fake whipping
story about
Biden keeps saying he wants to fund the
Border but Republicans won't let him but
that's another lie the Republicans
haven't had the power of the purse
strings in two years and Biden's budget
this year
slashes funding for the Border
Joe just went through the motions he
doesn't want to be there the man
couldn't wait to get back to Delaware
Texas governor Abbey waited for him on
the tarmac and handed him a list of
problems to fix but Biden didn't even
bother to read it
last week we told you about Biden's new
immigration plan you know because Kamala
couldn't deliver one Biden's new plan is
to give migrants a nap
where they can apply to come into
America before they even reach the
Border it's like TSA pre-check for
illegals all they have to do is say
they're scared of their home country and
they know a guy named Juan in the Bronx
it's like open table for illegals but
Biden knows that's not going to help
he doesn't even know what an app is to
him the Border crisis is unbeatable
there's no way to fix it unless you're
Magic
it's amazing
what do you think I could if I could
wave along
with Joe it's always about magic nothing
can be solved through leadership
remember when American parents were
going from store to store looking for
baby formula Biden said it's not his
fault he's not a mind reader
you have taken those steps sooner before
parents got to these shelves and
couldn't find Formula if we'd been
better mind readers I guess we could
have but we moved as quickly as the
problem became apparent to us to Biden
you can only solve problems if you're
David Blaine
wait a second where did he hear that
from
when somebody says
like the person you just mentioned who
I'm not going to advertise for
that he's going to bring all these jobs
back
well how exactly are you going to do
that what are you going to do
there's the there's no answer to it he
just says well I'm going I'm going to
negotiate a better deal well how
what how exactly are you going to
negotiate that
what magic wand do you have
now you know why nothing ever got done
under these two guys they're waiting on
a genie to pop out of a bottle
you don't need a wand Joe you just need
to enforce the law didn't you swear on
the Bible you'd enforce the law
hi Joseph Robinette Biden Jr do solemnly
swear that I will Faithfully execute
that I will Faithfully execute the
office of President of the United States
office of President of the United States
and will to the best of my ability we're
all to the best of my ability preserve
protect and defend preserve protect and
defend the Constitution of the United
States Constitution of the United States
you saw how easily they cleaned up the
border before Biden's visit why don't
they just pretend Biden's visiting every
day and just do it every day of the year
you don't need a magic wand for that